gracias por estar con nosotros en
reporteros bienvenidos a esta emisión en
la ciudad de goma en el este de la
república democrática del congo el
volcán en mira gongo entró en erupción
el 22 de mayo de 2021 despertando los
dolorosos recuerdos de la erupción del
año 2002 que le costó la vida a más de
3.000 personas
en esta oportunidad
milagrosamente la lava se detuvo a
portas de goma a unos cuantos cientos de
metros del aeropuerto pero no ocurrió lo
mismo con una decena de pueblos que sí
fueron alcanzados por la lava causando
la muerte de una treintena de personas
sin embargo los expertos están de
acuerdo la catástrofe tan temida tendrá
lugar algún día en esta ciudad con sus
casi dos millones de habitantes que
elecciones pueden sacar las autoridades
de la última erupción y cómo vivir con
esta amenaza permanentemente nuestro
equipo de reporteros acudió al lugar
[Música]
tomados de la mano fan y patrick
regresan por primera vez a la avalancha
de lava bajo la roca volcánica se
encuentra la casa que habitaron durante
17 años
17 años de vida destruidos en un
instante no veo una cerca a lo lejos lo
cual es eso lo que me permite reconocer
mi casa la cerca de las vecinas pero mi
casa ya no la veo la lava la tapó el
volcán se llevó todo esa noche funny
estaba trabajando su tienda su esposo
patrick que estaba en casa con sus siete
hijos de repente el cielo se iluminó la
lava descendió a la falda del volcán a
unos 100 kilómetros por hora y se tragó
todo a su paso
incrédulos patrick y sus hijos esperaron
hasta el último minuto para huir
sun y jong hay un banco y sin
discriminar con angus cuando vi mi casa
desaparecer casi me caigo mi cabeza daba
vueltas tuve entendí que mi vida se
volvería difícil a mi alrededor los
vecinos estaban locos
refugiados durante varios días en la
ciudad vecina de sake funk y patrick y
sus hijos regresaron a goma y se mudaron
a esta pequeña casa pero la familia aún
le cuesta dormir tranquila
más volcánico
cuando pienso en este volcán me digo que
aún puede despertar en cualquier momento
te tengo miedo la erupción dejó una
herida en mi corazón nunca nunca lo
olvidaría mundo
como fannie cerca de 2 millones de
personas viven bajo la sombra amenazante
del monte miran gongo a una altura de
tres mil cuatrocientos setenta metros es
uno de los volcanes más activos y más
peligrosos del planeta su particularidad
la presencia en su cráter de un lago de
lava cuasi permanente que en cualquier
momento puede escurrirse en 1977 y en
2002 el lago se vació brutalmente en
unos cuantos minutos una vez más los
vulcanólogos fueron sorprendidos
esperábamos inmediatamente esperábamos
en los años venideros por supuesto
porque el riesgo creció el nivel de lava
aumentaba el cráter pero no apostábamos
que la erupción tendría lugar en los
próximos días o en los próximos meses
entonces nos falta mucho por aprender
nos equivocamos está claro
para los científicos cada nueva erupción
es una oportunidad para entender mejor
el comportamiento del volcán hoy darío
tedesco y un equipo de investigadores
internacionales
senshan y estudia nuevas fracturas en
goma
es un aparato que nos permite medir los
flujos de co2 en el suelo aquí estamos
en la fisura de bujo fu estamos tratando
de medir de entender si aún hay dióxido
de carbono que se escapa de la fractura
aquí
cada fisura es una apertura potencial
para los ríos del agua haciendo estas
mediciones regularmente los
investigadores esperan identificar
nuevas señales que permitirían prever
futuras erupciones
medimos la presión medimos la
temperatura en la fractura
cuando notamos parámetros así podemos
tener una idea de una probable erupción
lo que no es fácil prever es el día o la
fecha de la erupción
pero al menos podemos tener una idea de
que el peligro es latente
conocer mejor el ir a congo para
anticipar mejor es la difícil misión del
observatorio vulcanológico de goma el
eje al día siguiente de la erupción del
22 de mayo fue parte de la polémica
acusado de no haber dado la alerta pero
según el director ninguna señal permitía
prever la erupción
y ya venir a
nuestro volcán tiene una particularidad
en la medida en que no contamos con una
historia muy documentada acabamos de
vivir la tercera experiencia
por acá pero entonces todos estos
parámetros entran en cuenta para que
podamos entender o predecir una erupción
del volcán y aragón el inicio de
si el volcán aún es desconocido el vg
dispone de medios suficientes para
develar sus secretos en el departamento
de sismología gentil jacques se le hacen
seguimiento a los temblores que podrían
indicar movimientos de magma
aquí tenemos un mapa que muestra los
epicentros con respecto a las estaciones
y nos llega en forma de señales y estas
señales las analizamos en estas máquinas
estamos haciendo un trabajo de
seguimiento cotidiano que los
investigadores no siempre pueden hacer
tras el final de una financiación del
banco mundial el año pasado el vg lo
contó con internet durante seis meses
entre octubre y abril el gobierno con
cuales debía tomar el relevo finalmente
fue una empresa estadounidense la que
restableció la conexión antes de la
erupción
si no tenemos internet cómo hacer
seguimiento en tendríamos que recoger
evidencia manualmente pero hay lugares a
los que no podemos llegar imagínense hay
14 15 estaciones tenemos incluso una
estación en el sur de kivú en bukavu a
más de 100 kilómetros en el eje a falta
de recursos no se limita a los cortes de
internet muchos equipos son vetustos
como estos vehículos a los que le cae
polvo en el parqueadero por falta de
mantenimiento otro ejemplo esta sirena
de alerta donada por la monusco que no
funciona desde hace años los
investigadores deben incluso renunciar a
ir a veces al terreno
soto no técnico lo hacemos a diario en
especial nuestros trenes pero queremos
que ocurra regularmente pero a veces
hacen falta recursos necesitamos
combustible muchas cosas
en 40 años de existencia las autoridades
congolesas no han conseguido autonomía
financiera para él vg el observatorio
dispone a pesar de todo de excelentes
recursos de seguimiento financiados casi
todos por socios extranjeros
online dicen distasio actualmente
contamos con una decena de estaciones
está bien interesante aunque
insuficiente pero con respecto a 2002
podemos decir que contamos con un equipo
que nos da información confiable en un
memorando destinado al presidente feliz
si se quería bruce días después de la
erupción un representante sindical
deplora la dependencia del vg de sus
socios extranjeros lo que asocia con una
especie de neocolonialismo alerta
también sobre los problemas del
clientelismo y corrupción
durante años los salarios de los
empleados así como millones de euros de
financiación extranjera habrían sido
desviados
y acabo la fracción
de saleh primero está la infracción
sobre el desvío de los salarios de los
agentes del estado
cuento con pruebas hubo financiación del
banco mundial la unión europea pero no
llegó al personal
bajo la presión de los empleados la
fiscalía de goma lanzó una investigación
el director general fue despedido en
enero por su lado el gobierno congolés
prometió apoyo financiero adicional
afirmó que nada sería como antes en el
vg
la erupción del 22 de mayo le recordó al
mundo entero la linaza que pesa sobre la
ciudad un peligro que no proviene
solamente del volcán sino también del
lago kivú que se extiende sobre 2.700
kilómetros cuadrados entre la república
democrática del congo y ruanda estas
aguas en apariencia apacibles contienen
a decenas de metros de profundidad
inmensas cantidades de gas metano y co2
equívocos jones barack y si sale con
frecuencia al lago para medir la tasa de
concentración
conocemos las concentraciones que el
lago tenía de todas estas medidas antes
de la actividad vulcano sísmica del 22
de mayo de 2021
ahora estamos ingresando puntos precisos
para hacer las mismas medidas y comparar
para tratar de entender si hubo
variaciones si hay de variación porque
el riesgo de ser de una erupción lírica
es decir la subida hacia la superficie
de todos estos gases sucedió en 1986
alrededor del lago nyos en camerún o una
explosión que acabó con todo a su paso
mató a más de 1.700 personas asfixiadas
en los minutos para el contexto es
diferente en el lago kivú más ancho y
más profundo los investigadores quieren
transmitir seguridad
de la que decimos que el agua está
estable pero que hay fenómenos que
pueden desestabilizar por ejemplo si hay
un temblor fuerte cuya magnitud por
ejemplo sea superior a 6.5 puede ser un
riesgo para el agua
una pequeña porción del lago preocupa
sin embargo a los expertos aquí en el
golfo de cabo no el agua está saturada
en co2 a unos 15 metros de profundidad
solamente un simple río de lava podría
provocar una catástrofe
este des cazador experimental fue
instalado en 2017 por un investigador
francés
y yo que la mente
de sus arengas hay un tubo que trae
estas aguas cargadas de gas es lo que
pueden ver de color blanco y ahí no en
otro
hay un tubo que lleva las aguas ya
desgastadas a la profundidad los 15
metros berlet es más
al día siguiente de la erupción el
gobierno congolés anunció el desembolso
de 4 millones de euros para descansar
totalmente el golfo de kabul y si la
extracción del co2 no ofrece salidas
económicas el gas metano puede ser usado
para producir electricidad es el caso en
ruanda que lanzó su programa kivuwatt en
2015 en la república democrática del
congo se firmó un acuerdo con una
empresa tunecina una central debería
surgir en los próximos años
pero de cualquier forma goma seguirá
viviendo bajo la amenaza de una
catástrofe mayor durante mucho tiempo
hay que resignarse entonces a verla
desaparecer este equipo de urbanistas
estudia la posibilidad de pasar una
parte de la ciudad hacia saque a unos 30
kilómetros al oeste
tomaremos las coordenadas de aquí le
llevaremos hasta el límite del parque es
necesario levantar las coordenadas en el
terreno con el fin de identificar las
tierras que pueden ser ocupadas por
terceros porque cuando hagamos ese
proyecto no debe haber conflicto por
indemnizaciones los expertos aconsejan
transformar estos espacios agrícolas
para implantar dos nuevas ciudades saque
2 y saque 3 que podrían acoger hasta
400.000 personas un proyecto titánico
que no ha sido estimado en cifras el
objetivo es localizar una parte de los
habitantes de los barrios más cercanos
al volcán y permitir una mejor
evacuación en caso de erupción bombas
judy zhu y castilla ya tres tengo más de
18 barrios hay 13 que están
superpoblados
densidades que van hasta 2.200
habitantes por hectárea
vimos lo que ocurrió el pasado 22 de
mayo en un pequeño eje comasa que no se
podía aquí donde hacíamos 20 minutos la
gente hizo tres horas 4
el proyecto está en el papel desde hace
años y algunos preferirían que no
saliera de ahí
al pie del volcán y aragón con los
habitantes no quieren irse para el uam y
el jefe tradicional la población está
acostumbradas desde hace siglos a los
sobresaltos de su vecino incómodo
la compilación
vemos que la población tiene una
relación sagrada una relación casi
divina con la tierra porque
tradicionalmente cuando alguien nace en
algún lado su cordón umbilical es
sembrado donde nació medical claudio
line
sólo tenemos esta tierra como casa a
donde iremos tras cada erupción el wami
y los suyos reconstruyen sobre la lava
endurecida una y otra vez ahora no será
la excepción
gracias por estar con nosotros en esta
emisión de reporteros recuerde que puede
ingresar a nuestra página web france 24
punto com para ver esta y las anteriores
hasta la próxima semana
[Música]